don't you dare buddy don't hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to subnautica now we've got
a bit of a crisis running out of power
we've got almost nothing left we got to
find a new location for our upgraded
base which is gonna have a ton of power
systems a lot of cool stuff great
features good looks totally handsome
this and an extra bathroom to boot oh
man my hands look awful so I need to
find a pristine location for my new base
and I'm thinking I know that I'm gonna
need some rather rare materials mixed
with a grab bag of pretty common stuff
I'm gonna put my base kind of like on
the precipice of this that way I'm close
to the main island with the big ol gun
I'm close to the Aurora just in case I
need to be near the Aurora and I
probably should have gotten mr. Pfister
damnit I probably should have gotten mr.
Pfister how much power I got probably
not enough you know there are each man
something something something don't seem
right here hmm Wow up and erect at the
moment okay to just dive back down here
okay let me see if I can see oh well
there's your problem
ah I'm an idiot that's your problem keep
food in food
I just garb down some of these bad boys
got mobile food wherever I go inventory
full cover up my [ __ ] ugly hands as he
munch munch munch munch and to piss to
wash it down alright we're good I feel
good who accepted all that piss but
that's okay alright so we got to get
going we got what I got to do is I have
all the materials necessary to build
another C month
and then I'm gonna call it a seamoth
until I actually get a name for it and I
need to look at you guys the comments
and then I'm gonna try to get the start
of a new base and this base is going to
be big it's going to be awesome and it's
gonna be epic those three categories
remember those those are very important
big something and epic hey Jeffrey
billets and wise and Marshall are you
doing Jeffrey Billy Sam Weiss Marshall I
don't remember if that was the name you
you know what I'm an abusive I'm a bad
I'm a bad father
I'll just say that I'm a bad father but
that's okay because you guys oh you guys
are gonna build me a brand new I could
build that but I don't have the cure yet
so give me a second I gotta go get that
personal propulsion I got an achievement
even though I've done this already put
my hands up I love watching you work I
just can't do it oh there she blows oh
man I had a bunch of upgrades in the
other one too I'm sad I'm sad these are
rotten why are they there hello hi Karen
you're not the same it's not the same
it's just not the same it's just not
okay so enough being a little [ __ ] I've
got this I'm gonna dock it in my big boy
here get right in there now we got to
come up with a solution for the power if
we can get a solution for the power gone
that means we got to get a bigger base
going so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
steal some materials from my old base I
don't know how much is left there but at
least I can salvage the solar panels off
the top of it you know the best way to
progress in life is to haphazardly rip
up everything in your past and use it
its fullest advantage don't care about
anything or nothing don't care about
what who it hurts nothing like that just
get it done
give me Oh
you needed copper that's weird
probably not that weird but okay and
these things needed more materials than
they used to this is [ __ ] oxygen
production of light I am sorry I'm very
sorry about that I need lead I know I
need that I haven't seen LED in a bit
lead yes please Gold yes please okay run
out of space maybe maybe I should get
rid of the rotten fish yeah all right
you know but just because you ask nicely
mmm maybe I could turn that into Lube I
should who love turning things into Lube
Wow that takes up all my space what am I
gonna get rid of my piss no way
you ain't separating me from that that's
so important to me for some reason
don't question me things go weird when
you're trapped alone all right it's all
good it's all good in this neighborhood
because that's all the stuff that we had
all right I'm Audi baby I love the
animations all right
so we're gonna take this we're gonna go
to a new space we're gonna build it up
it's gonna be great I'm gonna have fun
you're gonna have fun we're all gonna
have fun we're gonna have power more
importantly in there anything we're
gonna have power I don't want to be too
close that I would anger the reaper
leviathans but I want to be close
between two different biomes I kind of
wanted whoa whoa is that geothermal is
that just a frisky sand douche what is
that what's going on of the whoo
No now it's just a frisky sand douche
all right okay
I like the sounds hi welcome to the
party
you know why you sexy [ __ ] need to move
out of my place because I call this I
call dibs on all this you guys are gonna
learn what it's like when I call dibs
hmm I'm gonna go with Lube give me the
good stuff they are really rowdy out
there and I don't know why it's not even
stalker territory they're usually in the
grassy areas but new what are you gonna
do alright there's enough to get started
at least
alright let's build me off boys or no
one's here right
hey whoa buddy buddy buddy buddy boo
like you all right I want to kind of
overlooking the precipice into the abyss
so I always know that I'm gonna die they
are everybody all right you stopped by
some coral that sounds good it seems a
good place jenny was lay the foundation
down um well this foundations being all
stupid but you know it is what it is
okay let's try right there
lad lead and he's led since when do they
need land God they've changed everything
I don't know what you need what does it
mean anymore do this is everything
different what does it need lad lad
alright hey hey section okay alright
that's good alright I'm real happy about
that I don't like this at all okay well
this is a really shitty foundation
location not exactly what I was hoping
for but you know I'll take it
so don't have a lot of opportunity to
complain about stuff so I got to do what
I got to do I want to actually build a
competent room a good base our good base
I'll go base so a good base stalker
you're gonna be my friend right
be my friend how do I get more lad I
don't even know where to get lad I don't
even know what lead looks like what is
lad you led led let them know they're
now not led and not led lad
god I wish I had mr. Pfister oh hey
buddy how you doing oh sorry didn't mean
to interrupt a man ritual this is a
pretty good location because they got
red sand right there I think I've got oh
that is some kind of mushroom forest
that'll be good I've got a lot of
limestone outcroppings
led led yes
land okay good hey hey you hey hey not
necessary how much space I got not
enough leave one more lead
I need another lad that looks like a
lead no god damn it it's incredibly
disappointed let's just dump I don't
need this many [ __ ] what do I think
gonna happen gonna blow up oh whatever
oh oh hi stalky are you doing probably
fill up my tanks jaysus one more lead
place one more one more lead goddamn EU
sacks of [ __ ] or just tryin to kill me
or something it's almost as if you don't
want me building here it's open and I
can't imagine why I'm a friendly guy in
a friendly neighborhood anybody that
meets me knows that I'm a cool happening
dude that's not what I needed but uh
alright I'm not gonna say anything sassy
about anything because I gotta keep
moving give me some goddamn
you don't have let do you let all right
i'ma build another fiducia
and I got it all right time for a fun
douching all right let's build it
actually in line with everything okay I
got that build your legs there we go
that's nice
that's real nice okay let's build
another multi-purpose room feeling
frisky its builded it's gonna be the
entrance of this
I need another multi-purpose room the
moon pool is gonna be overhanging quite
a bit that's good it's starting to look
good it's starting to look real good oh
yeah that's nice there that's nice there
oh that's yeah
that's real nice okay what I gotta do is
I gotta find oh my god okay let's see if
I can make I need courts okay I need to
go get courts that's number one private
hey buddy just decided to give you a
little kiss smooch for the road maybe
the one problem with this areas no
courts okay cool we're good all right so
I'm just gonna be gathering for a while
everybody hold on it's gonna be a
compilation to me going ooh ah and then
screamingly old [ __ ] when I get killed
oh yeah oh yeah I really like this
location it's in the middle of a whole
bunch of good stuff and death it's also
in the middle of Death pull up pull up
let me drink a piss
maybe if I grab a corpse no drink the
pass don't drop it
drink it all right fine that pass is for
the Wolves maybe I should have built it
up there ooh that would have been a
slightly better hey cuz then I would
have been a little higher closer to you
know what I'm gonna do it it's not too
late to change it's never too late to
change every day is a new opportunity
yadda yadda yadda I'm just gonna be very
risky and I'm gonna drop everything in
my inventory right here so that I don't
lose it I just like this it's a good
outcropping okay that's all I good
that's literally all of my valuables now
I'm gonna turn my back for like two
seconds you guys don't go nowhere cause
I disassembled this [ __ ] now I got
you please don't kill me
oh okay yeah go for that guy yeah go for
that guy that guy's deserves that he
called you a little [ __ ] that's what
he called you I didn't know I didn't
want him to call you this is what
happened are you hoarding all that
Salvage you [ __ ] you'll [ __ ] I'm gonna
tame you up by boxes okay back to my bad
old habits yeah dude one do forget okay
all right we're good we're good we're
not good but we're getting good
we're gonna get good like the scrub I am
okay here we go foundation oh look at
them legs on you and you just got the
beefiest legs I ever did see I'm proud
of you oh yeah right on the back corner
there then that then the entrance is
gonna be right here oh it's gonna be
beautiful
oh she's gonna be a bit oh she's gonna
be a real yeah this one she's gonna be
up yeah ah she's gonna be a beaut
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
she's a beaut alright give me you give
me you me all the good stuff oh that's a
good hatch location you ever just look
at a hatch and you're like that's
alright setting it in for the long haul
you know it baby you know it alright let
me see if I can get some power in this
bad boy I try to be a nice guy I really
do try to be nice I'm like hey don't eat
me and then they eat me like [ __ ]
okay that's enough for now hopefully I
have enough to be able to make a
crafting kit to Bubba big box Barry over
there
cuz I don't want to cross that distance
anymore ah I'll add full baby ahead
flank it Alfred I complain about such as
noise
like how that other foundation doesn't
have legs but you know physics don't
need to work oh yeah it's time for the
big bump Bobo you're gonna yes we need
you
we're gonna need lots of you you mean
piss you talking about piss god I got
some piss you want to put piss back in
it all good it all good oh yeah that's
right that's what it's like oh is
building a base it is me it is me oh
let's get another one of these bad boys
off over here let's start the
ring-around-the-rosy process
I haven't care of da mang no sense
that's the good stuff now the other
reason that I'm building a base over
here is so that I could I just got some
celebration paths Oh girl drink that I'm
sure they are Karen I'm sure they are
now the other reason that I'm building
over here is because I'm close to the
portal being near that gun means I'm
close to the portal which can get me
anywhere in the system now you know if I
was smart I would do it a little closer
but you know I'm not smart so I'm not
even gonna talk about that but what I
can do is I can get more courts and keep
building this base up into something
good
at least something that I can fill the
moonpool out of how much do I need for a
moon pool hey I just need the lead okay
I just need lead so I just got to find
lead that's good
all right oh I love resource gathering
in the dark that's my favorite thing you
need courts lots of courts
hey buddy hey Don I'm on going this hole
with me ground quartz yeah it's the
quartz hole oh boy look at all this
quartz what I'm about to drown not with
this farting bubble right here let me
just get some of this brain coral shoot
it in my face up - I regret immediately
saying words that I just said I if I
could take it all back I didn't think
about it I really didn't think about it
oh look you can go up oh I'm sure this
can I get some explode Oh out of you yes
I got it
ha ha these networks popper ah enough
for more it's dark it's dark I don't
like the dark okay thank you
this is good baby I'm such a baby I got
I completely forgot I completely forgot
holy [ __ ] I completely forgot oh my god
alrighty then it's just like my nature
in this game to charge headfirst into
danger like no matter what I do hey
buddies no matter what I do you are much
more intimidating than you used to be I
don't know why do you have anything on
your surface that I can steal yeah
anything on your surface that I can
steal whoa crazy whoa cool break
barnacle yeah I'm sure he'll appreciate
that
oh no copper
got quartz quartz Sonya and more
barnacles yeah there's a particle okay
silver all right I'll take it
all right oh hell yeah and I'm close to
one of these I've been best route I
forgot I keep thinking I'm Spartan then
I'm not oh wait I'm not close I've just
gone really far away
oopsie-doopsie all right eventually I'm
gonna I'm gonna farm up a bunch of you
guys I'm up I'm gonna get a lawn of
defense I'm gonna keep everybody away
keep everything that could possibly harm
me away from me hey buddies
go poop go poop poop for me again
another thing I wish I never said all
right I'm actually good yeah son full of
a nice poop explosions Dan another thing
that I never thought I'd say out loud
anyway this is a really good place
because I'm surrounded like I'm in a
quadrant of good supplies here so if I
can just keep that and not die then I'm
fine
all right what am I gonna do okay so
what I need to do is I need to build the
fabricator that is the number one
priority on all these expeditions and
you go right there
and thankfully I don't need to be
computer chip for you so that's handy
dandy dandy duty
whoo you know what I can do oh you know
what I can do yes yes yes
storage storage yes wall lockers yes yes
I can do the wall lockers oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah you know what
I'm gonna do next I'm gonna go find some
names oh hell to the yeah alright so
I've got some names here I just saw only
have room for two names the first one
goes to jester J who said I think you
should build a giant shrine in memory of
bubble blood fill it with a bunch of
tributes for your lost friend and I
completely agree I think if anything I'm
gonna put the Keep Calm build a shrine
oh all right okay yeah let me let me
here's this shrine is gonna be right
here Oh in commemoration of bubble-butt
oh no it's so sad how do I use this edit
sign big big big big big in memoriam oh
[Laughter]
god I'm really sad about this I should
build like a desk or something or a
counter at least or a bench oh no how do
I like this nice bench oh that I can put
some stuff on right there
no I'm charming wait hang on whoa whoa
whoa I've said no net hang on get in my
mouth
get in my mouth get in my mouth ah get
in my mouth why can't I pick you up get
in my mouth in my mouth oh okay that was
good
no siliceous yum yum yum give me you I
was in the middle of morning I was
mourning the loss boop boop II do
oh my god I was in the middle of
something it's not my fault that I
forgot the game's fault we're getting it
the way jeez Oh God I am ingredients I'm
an idiot half the comments should be I'm
just an idiot all right okay and aimless
films aimless shrooms
okay are aimless films aimless booms all
right said this episode had a really
good plotline it almost seems scripted
and I wish I really wish I was smart
enough to be able to script half of the
[ __ ] that I go through in this game but
that's the beauty of subnautica I have
honestly have no idea what to expect
almost all the time that I'm playing
this game I can have a good rough idea
of what I want to accomplish but the
beauty of it like there's so many things
that can just throw a wrench in your
plans that nothing ever ever ever goes
according to plan oh God and I'm such an
idiot than I forget so much so often
anyway
power transmitter that's really
important if I get like a geothermal
somewhere I could probably do that
oh man let me make one more copper wire
because I I need to I need to make
another sign this is really really sad
oh geez
all right not you not you buddy all
right let's see right there that's good
all right bubble butt oh so sad okay but
anyway I will I will carry on without
bubble butt I haven't gotten a name for
the new ship yet I feel like either you
guys will suggest it or it'll come to me
and I'll do more more of these lockers
in the next episode I'm gonna try to do
a little bit of resource gathering in
between this and the next one so thank
you everybody so much for watching I'm
glad you're with me on another adventure
it's gonna be a lot of fun so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]